pendant plusieurs jours des paysans
indiens ont réussi à faire croire qu'ils
étaient des joueurs poule derrière leur
écran des russes pensez à regarder et
parier sur des matchs officiels la
police a fini par intervenir et arrêté
plusieurs organisateurs selon le chaque
match leur rapporter plus de 600 jeunes
quand vous vous tenez dans le studio
vous pouvez être téléporté dans
n'importe quel appareil dans le monde et
la caméra devant moi me permettre
d'interagir avec mon public donc je peux
voir et discuter avec n'importe qui que
ce soit dans le monde et nous donne
du plaisir des bolides et en clin d'oeil
bien sûr un autre icône du rock n roll
ben ça ne l'aide pas c'est une tollé des
minutes quand je marche bah je sais pas
mais à gainsbourg
n'oubliez pas le geste
car sur son devoir cacher ce sexe que
l'on ne saurait voir que les yeux
patrick dancoisne transforme le mauvais
goût henri bour n'est pas trop réussi
mais bon on voit bien que maintenant
c'est plus c'est quand même revenu
transformé les gens ils sont bien
contents qu'on m'eut ch 1 sec son animal
ça leur fait plaisir pour la vue des
enfants surtout emmanuel macron vous
aviez dit que ça lui en toucher une
champions bouger l'autre sur les yeux
balle et hubert fine voilà et donc sur
cette formule là la france a appris
effaré qu'il en avait au
bahreïn aurait donné par un président ne
devrais pas dire ça mais ben ali
consultant sur le sac ne devrais pas
dire ça sans qu'il le des effaceurs du
tour deviennent vite de leur popularité
s'était librement dessiner une pour pour
les voir pour voir si le la légende
était vrai et prins trouve qu'en fait
les gendarmes sont passés avant la
légende et ils nous ont demandé du coup
de dépasser la quiche alors la place des
eph a sorti en fait c'était à l'époque
où il préparait les présidentielles
j'essayais de sarko lui conseillaient
justement d'aller plus souvent sur les
plateaux télé histoire de donner une
bonne image du voile avoir l'air sympa
et là il a rétorqué est ce qu'on demande
à rocco siffredi d'avoir des sentiments
voilà et au passage c'est son ancien
conseiller patrick buisson qui a balancé
l'info dans un livre c'est une
discipline acrobatique et citoyenne
dont les amateurs sont de plus en plus
nombreux sur les réseaux sociaux
des équipes et dans les centres villes
pour traquer et quitte indre une à une
les enseignes qui restent allumés la
nuit un défi que ces quatre amis se
lancent régulièrement dans les rues de
paris ces travaux d'agrandissement
atteste du succès croissant de l'école
le bâtiment fait cinq mètres de long sur
10 mètres de large six mètres de haut
alors on a besoin de 20 mille cadavres
de bouteilles pour faire tous ces murs
si on utilisait du béton père est 20
fois le prix des bouteilles nous on s'en
sort à moins de 100 dollars nous sommes
retournés voir ces commerçants dont les
enseignes ont été éteintes la nuit
dernière
cette lumière et ce logo ça nous permet
d'être visible aux gens du quartier et
bah du coup comme c'est un bain on ne
voit pas donc après c'est quelque part
c'est aussi tout le travail qu'on fait
au quotidien derrière que c'est nuisible
à notre travail aussi je pense
s'il dit est toujours là où on ne
l'attend pas
elle a demandé à la production de louer
ce chalet au coeur des vosges
treize ans après son tube papillon de
lumière la chanteuse aspire à présent un
quotidien plus serein
fans de gros bout
[Musique]
skippy le kangourou
[Rires]
le droit bout c'était d'emmener leurs
fonds il y avait un petit bourg où est
maman gourou humam ans et romeo c'est
cool que tu arrêtes la matinale notre
boulot comme ça tu pourrais être là avec
nous les petits déj on écoutera à france
inter
voici la seule photo qui existent de
l'un des épisodes les plus noires de
notre histoire pendant cinq jours à
l'intérieur du vel d'hiv
8160 personnes dont la moitié d'enfants
sont entassés sans nourriture 1 seul
point d'eau et une chaleur étouffante
après plusieurs semaines
rachel g10 nacre trouve enfin la trace
de sa mère
une revanche sur la vie mise à l'honneur
par la ville de saint cyprien qui lui a
donné un nom de rue et bien un drôle de
faire pour s'aider d'avoir la nausée rue
de son vivant c'est assez rare quel
dommage c'est quand tu es bête les noms
des rues marc en dessous qu'est ce qu'on
a fait ça sert à quoi il aurait pu
mettre la rue des papillons ou la rue de
ce qu'ils voulaient c'était pareil